and matt boyd is on the mound the
left-handers era doesn't look pretty but
dan lately he has been figuring it out
again his last two starts have been
better scott i think one of the keys for
matt boyd is keep the ball at the
ballpark he's had a very difficult time
giving up runs in the first inning we
had a chance to talk to ron garden
higher before the game he would like to
see him use a better variety of his
pitches
he elevates and picks up the strikeout
and you know you see right here garcia
swinging up and out of the zone and one
aboard for christian yelich down on the
1-2 saw very few swings in 2019 like
that from christian yelich and another
walk so two strikeouts and two walks
from boyd so far he jammed him and matt
boyd strands the two runners and gets
through the first unscathed so here's
corbin bernstein making his sixth start
and in his first five his era is under
two that earned run average includes
three relief appearances as well he's
finding it there's a really good pitch
right there outer third
right on the corner now the big man
miguel cabrera goes after the first
pitch and sends it to center avasyl
garcia working with it three up three
down for corbin burns including two
strikeouts we are scoreless after one
between the brewers and the tigers the
ground rule double for the brewers
shortstop here's luis arias and he
shoots a ball to the left and that finds
some open space and that'll score the
first run of the game arcia trots home
it's an rbi double for luis serious one
nothing milwaukee good hustle right
there by aureus too that's a ball that
got in the gap didn't shoot it and arias
does a great job of getting out of the
box fast thinking double right when he
hit he thought i'm getting i'm getting a
two
great piece of base runner right there
that's not that bad of a walk with a
base open right there sean you do set
yourself up for the double play that
pitch is south to left another one
another one similar spot avasale garcia
connects
and the brewers have another boy this
has been a struggle this second inning
so far from that boy matt boyd going up
against jed jerko right now uh-oh go jed
jerko going the other way
forget about it
muscles up for his sixth home run of the
season and the brewers are up four
nothing that's the pitch i'm talking
about up and away above the zone jerko
does a great job kind of staying above
the baseball keeping his hands level and
really driving down through it and he's
able to create some great backspin to
get that ball off the right is an
infield knock for tyrone taylor
nottingham lifts that one deep to left
and bonifacio will give it a look he has
no play it's gone
jacob nottingham powers up for two and
milwaukee's up six zip well the home run
has cost matt boyd we touched on it
coming into the start
50 home runs he's allowed since the
beginning of the 2019 season brew crew
playing some long ball second home run
they've hit on the day on the first base
he goes and garcia will move his way up
as well
ryan braun pass short stop and that is
going to be
yeah he's in there he's safe
avasale garcia scores with a smile and
ryan braun drives in the seventh run for
milwaukee and the story line belongs to
corbin burns perfect through four days
well 12 up 12 down after the castro
ground out and that one going to deep
right center and it is high off the wall
first hit of the day for detroit willie
castro with a triple off of corbin burns
here in the fifth
six game hit streak hitting over 400
during that span spoils the perfect game
bid and the no no
two triples on the year for castro
avasale garcia has his second double of
the day he's reached base three times
unleashes there you go and finds plenty
of open real estate and that's gonna
bring in garcia that's the swing that we
saw last year in 2018 that made this guy
a national league mvp base is loaded now
and luis arias will step in that one is
shipped to left and it's going to fall
in fair ground and it'll clear the bases
luis arias with the double to knock in
three it's 11 nothing milwaukee this
game is for the most part out of hand
hit parade continues tyron taylor is
feeling good urea scores 12-zip
milwaukee
that left-field corner is getting worn
out
i'd love to see this guy swinging like
that ryan braun goes long
wrong for two it's 15 nothing
no you you hang one to ryan braun like
that you hang and he bangs it that ball
was out over the plate just kind of
sitting up there with he was able to
really get his arms extended and really
skies this ball to left field
corbin burns is the starter for
milwaukee still going strong
corbin burns right now stepped in a big
old bucket of sassy
he's been good all year but this is the
best i've ever seen corbin burns and
what i really liked he was pitching with
a lot of positivity and a lot of energy
milwaukee pouring on 15 runs this
afternoon jericho launches oh there's a
good buy
shake rattle and roll right there a
little two homer day for jet jurka
for out number two and what was more
impressive it's not easy to pitch when
you have such a big lead brewer's had a
couple of long innings and burns was
able to stay focused and composed and
that'll do it that's right caught by
taylor
who had a big day